في لفته الطيبه وعمل انساني نبيله قامت
عائله سعوديه حفل زفاف لعمل لديها اسمه
جهير وشاركته هذه الفرحه لفت جميله جدا
ووثق مقطع فيديو متداول لحظات اقامه
الزفاف وظهر العريس مرتديا الثوب والبشت
السعودي تزفه سيارات وسط اجواء من الفرحه
والسعاده الفيديو المتداول لحفل الزفاف
اثار تفاعلا واسعا من رواد مواقع التواصل
الذي رحبوا بتصرف الاسره لنتابع ذلك
الفيديو
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا الان مشاهدينا محمد القمقوم رب
الاسره السعوديه والعريس جهير طبعا معنا
من الرياض اهلا وسهلا فيكم صباح الخير
ومبارك الف الف مبروك يا رب يعني هذا
الزواج وخليني ابدا معك استاذ محمد
لفته جميله وانسانيه يعني بشكل هائل ليش
قررتوا يعني انكم تحتضنوا جهير لهذه
الدرجه لحتى تزوجوه كمان
اولا بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
صباح الخير
اختي راويه يا اخي عادل حياكم الله حياك
الله وجهك الله يحييكم زهير طبعا عمل معنا
وقت يعني الحمد لله من اربع سنوات الى خمس
سنوات لاحظنا فيه
الامانه والاخلاص والتفاني وحبه العمل
واعجبنا اكثر فيه
بره بوالديه يعني
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
هل انت فرحان شنو اللي يعني لك انه انه
هذه الاسره السعوديه تقيم لك هذا العرس مو
في بنغلاديش في السعوديه
السلام عليكم انا اشكركم وانا حبي زياده
سعوديه عربيه انا ما شاء الله
قبل شوف في حفله صديق انا سعودي انا رو ما
شاء الله تبارك الله يجي يعني كويس انا
يعني كلام
بنغلاديش انت لازم
يجي انا شويه كده
بعدين
انا موجود سعودي قريبة ماما بابا مدام
وانا حق جواز حفله ما شاء الله سوي بابا
ابو طلال مساعده سمسم جواز سعودي جزاك
الله خير وشكرا لكم مملكه روبيه السعوديه
وانا مقصد زياده هذا قلب زهير سعودي الله
تستاهل هذا قلب سوداء والله واحنا كمان
معانا في صباح العربيه ابو طلال حبيت
اسالك يعني كيف كيف رتبته للموضوع العروس
مثلا هي كانت اصلا ببنغلاديش وانتوا يعني
جبتوها على السعوديه مع والد والده زهير
كيف كانت الترتيبات والمعازيم ايضا
اولا حياك الله اختي راويه بالنسبه
لترتيبات التي صارت بعد ما تم عقد زواجير
على عروسته تم بدء باجراءات
استخدامهم من المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وتم الانتهاء منها بفضل الله بوقت قياسي
والحمد لله
وبعد ان تم انتهاء جميع الاجراءات الحمد
لله تم وصولهم الى ارض المطار وتم عمل
استقبال لهم من قبل العائله كما شاهدته في
بعض الفيديوهات وبعد وصولهم طبعا
الاجراءات الحمد لله من يوم بدا زهير
تقديمات الاغراض من شهرين الى شهرين ونصف
الحمد لله كله جاهز لانه
فاجاني قال ابي اعمل عرس مثل العرس
السعودي فقلت ابشر انا حاضر باللي تبغي
ابو طلال خلي اسالك انه خلنا واقعيين
اليوم اليوم مو كل واحد من الممكن انه
العامل لديه في المنزل
يسوي لها العرس ويزين لها هالليله هذه
ويرتبها الامور شو اللي خلاك انه والله
يعني جهير تقوم بتجهيز هذا العرس وتحمل
تكاليفه
وتسوي له عرس سعودي مثل ما هو يبي
[موسيقى]
العمل هذا العمل الخيري وبعدين العمل هذا
انا لاحظت فيه يعني احبه ورغبته اني احقق
لها الامنيه وادخل السرور عليه وعلى
عائلته والحمد لله والعائله عندي برضو
عملت كفريق واحد يعني معي لا انسى طبعا في
هذه المناسبه هذه المقابله ام طلال برضه
زوجتي قامت برضه باعمال ثانيه
من استقبال العروس وعمل الكوشه لها
والذهاب الى صاله الحفل مثل ما يعمل
للعريس السعودي يعني عملنا غرفه عمليات
صغيره
نعم
بانجاز هذا العمل يعني والحمد لله انا
لاحظت الفرحه على ابوه استخدمنا طبعا ابوه
وامه معاه وب بالحفل ومبسوطين بس للاسف
شوي اللغه العربيه عندهم ما في لغه عربيه
عندهم
وانبسطوا يعني لما تلقوا الدعوه انبسطوا
اكيد والله جزاكم الله كل خير ابو طلال
انت وام طلال وعائلتك الكريمه يعني هذه
اللفتات الانسانيه هي اللي بتخلي الناس
تحس بانه الدنيا لسه بخير فانا بدي اسال
بس اخر شيء تفضل تفضل ابو طلال لا لو
سمحتوا في اطراء بسيط بس يعني ملي يشكر
الناس ليشكر الله خال العيال زعل عيد برضو
جزاه الله خير لما سمع بالمبادره هذا كان
متكتمين عليها ما نبيها تطلع طلعت للاعلام
من الله سبحانه فاتبرع لهم بشقه مقابل
بيته الف مبروك
ان شاء الله اذا اذا جاك ولد ايش راح
تسميه يا زهير
اول بيبي ان شاء الله
ممكن بيبي اول ولد جيد يركبني ابو طلال
الزهير ان شاء الله
دائما مبسوط زياده
سلام ان شاء الله افطر تاني ان شاء الله
ماما
مدينه ان شاء الله
ان شاء الله
يعطيكم العافيه شكرا
هذا السعودي فوق فوق اي والله
الف الف مبروك وشكرا جزيلا على وجودكم
معنا طبعا
ابو طلال القمحوم رب الاسره السعوديه
والعريس جاهير كان معنا في صباح العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات